des vrombissements entendues à quelques
kilomètres de montoir ce week-end pas
ceux de grosses cylindrées non mais de
tracteurs tondeuses première course du
genre à savigny sur braye les équipes
s'affrontent sur des bolides lancés à 80
km/heure dans une belle ambiance le
reportage de samuel colin
cela ne leur feront pas votre jardin
constr acteurs leurs pilotes pied au
plancher objectif faire en une heure et
demie le plus de troupes possible et
assuré le spectacle en bord de piste ça
change d'autres courses jeu très bien on
mange un peu plus chers c'est parce
qu'on veut bien plus de poussière que
pelouse effectivement le jury lui pour
voir tout ce qu'il se passe ne pourrait
pas être mieux installé on compte les
tours et à une heure et demie entre une
demi-heure et ensuite encore une heure
et demie mais ce matin hier les essais
libres et chronométrés 50 bénévoles
travaillent sur cette course la première
de ce genre ici organisée avec le comité
des fêtes pour dynamiser le village ses
sympathies à la famille et de bois
d'oeuvre des vers en fait est de faire
venir du monde quatre cents personnes
environ dont les compétiteurs venus de
bourges tours et les alentours chaque
équipe à trois pilotes ils se relaient
autant qu'il le souhaite on a perdu de
tanger quartier une fois le moteur j'ai
réparé vitré on est ressortis deuxième
fois parce que on avait perdu des
boulons du ta peau j'ai hâte d'y
retourner les tracteurs les plus
performants frôle les 80 km/heure et
pour atteindre ces vitesses c'est toute
une mécanique à adapter on a juste
modifié les transmissions un peu le
carburateur on fabrique des prototypes
qu'on échange toute la transmission on
met un arbre complet mais la plupart des
pièces sont d'origine et parfois la
passion ne suffit pas il arrive que ça
casse sa vie n'est pas de première
manche athlètes vous saviez vous avez
été 3e et primes à la casse et le train
arrière du tracteur
je vais essayer de le démonter pour
pouvoir réussir à le re soudée
et cette première édition trace le
chemin pour les organisateurs et leur
nouvel objectif des 24 heures de
tracteur tondeuse l'année prochaine